looks as though the government is not
for any more u-turns
well look it's very clear now isn't it
it's becoming clearer and clearer every
day that that passes that they've
absolutely got to go back to the drawing
board uh with this so-called mini budget
it has led to a huge loss of confidence
in our government and its ability to run
the economy and that is leading very
directly to these huge rises in mortgage
rates that we're seeing that every
working person who has a mortgage in
this country is now paying the price for
as well as a continued uh problems with
inflation and so on so they've got to go
back to the drawing board I don't think
there's any doubt about that now uh I
think the the the issue is will that be
enough and will they get the confidence
of some of these financial institutions
which frankly they've also trashed over
the last few weeks by not publishing uh
the report of the office for Budget
responsibility alongside their budget
and by trashing uh the top people who
work in the treasury all of these things
is what has led to this total loss of
confidence and it's ordinary working
people paying the price for it
um nevertheless it looks as though um
they are not for any more u-turns um
what would you say to the uh quasi
quattanker as we know has gone to
Washington to speak to the IMF uh they
have been
um pretty critical actually as far as
the British economy is concerned what
would you say to quasi quite ahead of
that Halloween budget
well look he's he's got to reverse uh
his his mini budget because the sons
just don't add up yeah we've heard the
Prime Minister yesterday saying that she
is absolutely uh not for cutting public
spending
um good I'm pleased to hear her saying
that but she cannot sustain that at the
same time as a sustaining huge tax cuts
for some of the the biggest and most
well-off businesses in this country and
other tax plans that she had in her mini
budget and she also can't sustain that
with the energy price freeze being
funded entirely from borrowing and not
raising money as we have been proposing
from a windfall tax on the excess
profits of the energy companies so I
think you know quasi-corting and the
Prime Minister can put their finger in
their ears and say it's all okay we'll
carry on as normal and we'll all
continue to pay for that with increased
mortgage rates with inflation out of
control and other prices going up or
they can do the responsible thing and
listen uh not just to the big economic
Global institutions like the IMF listen
to Parliament listen to the public and
they can reverse their mini budget and
go back to the drawing board and I think
it's now incredibly clear that that
they've got to do that and it's not it's
not even that clear whether that alone
would be now sufficient to restore
confidence but I think that's a an
absolutely first step to restoring some
confidence
okay but even if they did reverse
everything that they they gave away uh
in the last budget in the mini budget
that's 40 odd million quid the black
hole is 62 million pounds so far
unlikely to increase further how would
you pay for it
well look it's as you say it's about the
the package overall isn't it and you
know there were some big decisions there
that they that they taken that have led
to that black hole being as big as it is
um and the first of those is the uh
planned increase in corporation tax
which uh after covid and after all the
sort of support that's gone into
businesses uh it was decided that there
should be increases over the coming
years in corporation tax so that's a tax
on big businesses that make profits so
that's that's all that that is and that
would amount to around 18 billion pounds
a year that they said they were going to
just cut that it's unfunded and that's a
big problem so they need to reverse that
uh The Cutting stamp Duty with it which
is effectively a bonus to landlords and
second homeowners as we've seen from
previous times as stamp duties being cut
they need to reverse uh that too and
then critically on this issue of the
energy try threes and where the money is
going to come from they need to swallow
their ideology and accept that these
super massive excess profits that the
energy companies are now raking in uh
need to be uh have a windfall tax to
help to pay for that and that all of
that together we think would would help
to restore confidence and credibility
and make the sums uh add up much better
than they do at the moment
talk to me about the Online safety bill
that's very much part of your brief
isn't it we're being told that you know
it's been pushed back again
um we are being told though by the
cultures actually that it will be put to
Parliament again soon we've heard that a
lot of times previously uh why the
continued delay can the labor not do
anything about that and what in
particular do you want to make sure gets
through
well look as you say I mean we cannot
afford any more delay with with this
bill we we've had weeks of this bill
going through Parliament uh before
before the summer we needed one last bit
of a half day debate to finish it off
before it went uh to the Lords before
the government pulled it we've been
waiting for it for three or four years
it's been promised time and time again
and of course most recently we've heard
the uh the devastating findings from the
Molly Russell coroners uh case about the
real impact of the the sort of business
models and the algorithms and the
pushing of content towards young people
that leads to suicide and harm and so
the urgency is now and and I've uh I've
written to the culture secretary to say
I will do whatever it takes to make time
in Parliament to work with the
government to get this done and get it
done quickly Before Christmas isn't soon
enough uh every week in this country
we're seeing uh three or four Teenage
ages take their own lives and many of
those are linked to activity on social
media so we we cannot afford to wait and
I will do whatever it takes uh to get
this bill it's not perfect there are
things about it that I I would change
but let's not make Perfection the enemy
of the good we need to get a regulation
and get a regulator in as quickly as
possible I've never heard that phrase
before Perfection the enemy of the good
um I've I'm going to use that it's good
to talk to you thanks so much India for
joining us
thanks okay